hey rainy licky here with my twin
brother Brendon Walsh what is Brendon
Walsh Amos Oh Amos and Lisa what do you
think about the show what'd you think
about the show what do you think about
the show everybody was really good I was
incredible show was amazing I don't know
you seen bill burr perform podcast cool
well it's nice to meet you bill burr
nice to meet you I was laughing at the
missing paraphernalia I've lost my
temporary crown you lost a tooth from my
comedy have you ever laughed your damn
teeth out - bill burr joke cheddar than
bill berg oh the only time she ever
laughed her damn teeth that was to burn
in Walsh Jo oh yeah there's a missing
tooth do you have a favorite Brendon
Walsh Brendon Walsh well take a look
right there burnin Walsh's right there
my favorite part of the show is Feldberg
I heard he was he did a thing where he
he bill burned someone and the audience
I heard now you see this is interesting
I heard he got booed offstage mm-hmm
that's booing I'll take that any time
but this is what I heard he got booed
off the stage and then out the door
around the corner then back into the
theater and back onto the stage and then
got a standing ovation you got to see a
super handsome guy crack you up
real easy on the eyes and real tickle
into the funny bone if you want to hear
if you want to hear more he has a
podcast called the bone zone on all
things comedy and you should listen to
it because he's just as funny on that
but if you but you should be careful
your dental bills could add up you know
Randy and I are twins me and Randy are
twins
we're identical twins but our birthdays
are on different days you ever hear
anything like that his birthdays today
mine was yesterday cuz I was born at
11:59 p.m. oh wow he's born at 12:01
a.m. different fathers nope today's his
birthday
mine was yesterday
born at 11:59 p.m. and and you'd think
that a doctor would round up or round
down but our doctor was a real hippie
dippie I was born in a beanbag chair and
he was like let's give him different
birthdays and though we do in a
dreamcatcher yeah for do you guys have
girlfriends I have a girlfriend yeah
yeah she's here where is she I don't
want a point she's over there she's
looking for the girl with the biggest
honker I'm spoken for so I'm dating the
Los Angeles Lakers cheerleaders tonight
is dating the Laker Girls
no they're waiting for me back home yeah
it is right love you too hate your
husband thank you love you hate your
husband love you hate your husband
well Randy I think that was another
successful interview it was this is
Brendon and Randy signing off for all
things comedy for all things comedy calm